this is a pepper panic saga level 89 walkthrough video
we're going to complete the level
and were going to explain our
decisions as we go
I made this video yesterday afternoon
for a request that I had in our group
pepper panic add me and level tips
and because i played a little faster I think I
missed a few points I'm recording a new audio track over top and
going to pause the video here and there so
that I can explain why I did what I did
I'm if you play the summer before you
know it's difficult
and difficult for a few different
reasons
the statues are hard to get to
are your master closet there
he's out the other papers im get ready
your progress
when you need to do is mean to grow
yellow and red peppers
that arcade below to explode them
whether sitting right next to the statue
and you have to avoid mister causation
go
so in the beginning
with him starting at the top
we wanna I'm restore to grow our read
more yellows
but we're looking for other matches that
will bring more those on
the border while
he's up there so that we won't really
lose any red yellows
as he moved his way down so
the first couple matches we make ur
gonna be just be too
drop newspapers on the board and then we
get this one here that's a vertical
shockwave
was gonna hit a statue so we want to
make that all the time
and we just wanna keep continuing the
clear out space in
set up more radio
im even when you see in the last 30 min
whenever you hear
whenever you are the Omega I make a mess
is not important or
grozny's papers when they drop you can
get good matches now on this next one we
can match the
red pepper on the left with the one
grown
ever that we have and then that's gonna
cause the two above it to drop to make
another batch right away so we'll make
that much
are them with us look over the border in
C mister causes down toward the bottom
now so now we want to just throw them as
fast as we can
at the top
on this when we don't really have a
great match the only way to move the red
one of the side by itself we will match
that with this
minutes making out in the middle now to
bring more
papers and this is a good one
Pausa for that that was a good match
because it set up the fact that progress
and that'll knock him out for one woo
and rodeos really quickly all the red
as the cages were all those
was for another adhere curtain whatever
whenever the more clears out whichever
recover much growth we have it'll add to
that by
the cages protector he goes by
no when you're making your decisions
appear mean you you do want to
it it's ideal to focus on one color but
what I said about the cages
means that grown either one is gonna be
okay
and like I said in the guy
the which if you haven't read our full
ever panic saga level 89
guided democratic this I suggest you do
that first
because you understand a little bit more
about why we're doing what we're doing
but
a you definitely need to
a make matches that will bring
lots love these colors red and yellow
peppers on the board so that you can
here continue to explode now will search
a reaction that the red
and that'll give us a lot of damage to
the statues mister
are the sometimes when you're doing that
yellow in fall in place and they
can remove their that some other statues
arm it's not ideal but it's fine
and we still want to grow the yellow
because there's another them that are
they're gonna do damage this that you so
will continue trying to grow really
and see you wanna keep making matches
they're going to line things up you know
much like that one
the you're definitely gonna make it
that's going to grow your this one is a
little less than ideal because get a
free this one from the cage
but there's no other good matches look
around the board
to make so this is gonna be the best
match
and see the radar really important it
all the more you dismiss those whatever
they're gonna set up a match report for
okay so when you get to this point
you don't really have a lot to get hella
messes up to
and this is
this'll make up States Private more
certain explosion
so you're gonna make this match more
for the fact that it brings more papers
there
because you can't really protect the
ones they have a problem you can imagine
for
now the screaming it's unclear roanoke
Libra drop a yellow
onto the board for the weekend explode
from for
here
where you don't really want to move them
away from the stage is when you have to
get a chain reaction we only have four
for matches performers look listen to
and we got a little a little bit lucky
with the drop there where we got a shock
wave going crosswise but
we made the best moves as we were and
that's all you can really do
you can't plan on the lock but it
happens and
you know making the right decision makes
him more likely that it's gonna happen
so I hope that this was helpful
and you'll be able to complete the level
after watching it
as mention this was a this was for
requests in our group
you're welcome to join the the address
is in the description in this video
we have a lot of players there who are
helpful like the
you know talk about the the different
levels and how they got room
make sure you are take a second to
like this video be found it helpful and
subscribe to our channel:
those things really help us out as far
shown up in the search for you too
and we appreciate it when you do that
you going questions leave a comment
below and
hopefully you finish the level right now
thanks